This example extends the UIView class
to enable a view to fade out and
fade back in.
For this demo, we'll be looking
at a really simple Xcode project.
Go ahead and download it from the link
in the instructor's notes, and
then open the project in Xcode.
It's called FadeExtensionDemo.
In this left panel,
the project navigator,
click on the ViewController file.
And then, look for
the sunrise and set method.
Here inside sunrise and set,
you can see that I'm using the method,
animateWithDuration, to
fade out an image view.
This animation changes the view's
alpha value from one to zero
over the duration that I
pass in as a parameter here.
This one is one second.
There's also a delay parameter, so
we could pass in a delay if we wanted.
Under the options parameter you'll
see we've passed in CurveEaseIn.
This makes it so
that the animation starts out slow and
speeds up towards the end.
For the completion parameter,
I'm passing in some code
that changes the image.
And then, fades the view back in.
Here's the code that changes the image.
After the image is changed,
we're using animateWithDuration
again to fade the view back in.
You can see that this code for
fading the view back in is identical
to the code that phased it out.
Apart from the alpha value and
the completion parameter.
The syntax around this completion
parameter is pretty tricky.
So don't worry if it doesn't
make sense right now.
We'll talk more about completion
blocks in the next lesson on closures.
I want to focus on another
problem with this code.
Soon I'll have another view that I'd
like to fade out and fade back in.
And I know I'd have
to rewrite this code.
That goes against my dry
programming principles.
But if I put this code in an extension,
I can reuse it.
So let's do that, since I can't add an
extension directly to the UIView Swift
file, I'll make a new Swift file and
call it UIViewExtensions.
To add a file to the project, I just
Ctrl+click on one of these folders,
over here in the project navigator,
and then I go to New File.
Then I want a Swift file.
And again,
I'm going to call it UIViewExtensions.
Here we are in
the UIViewExtensions.swift file.
And the first thing you'll
need to do is import UIKit.
To define an extension,
you just write the word extension
followed by the name of
the type you're extending.
And in between curly braces,
the methods you'd like to add.
The methods we'd like to add
are called fadeOut and fadeIn.
Here in the fadeOut method,
we just want to copy and
paste some of the code from
that sunrise and set method.
So to do that we go back to
our ViewController.swift file.
And then,
we want to copy this fade out code,
this animateWithDuration code, up to but
not including the completion block.
Once you've got
animateWithDuration pasted in,
there are a couple snippets
of code we need to edit.
Here where it says self.imageView.alpha,
we want to replace that with self.alpha.
Because the object that's
calling this code,
self is the object whose
alpha needs to change.
Next, we need to make sure we're
passing in the necessary parameters.
So we'll pass the parameters
duration delay, and
the completion closure
into the fade out method.
And then, we'll pass those
parameters again to the animate with
duration method.
So here, instead of one
second we'll put duration.
Here, instead of a delay of
zero seconds we'll put delay.
And then, under completion,
we'll put completion.
Notice that the animation option,
CurveEaseIn is the same every
time fade out is called.
And so, is the animation
changing the alpha to zero.